And if I keel over
and fall down,
somebody call the ambulance.
OK, what we're going
to do today is,
this is actually the
last lecture on a topic
that some might consider
part of networking,
but some might consider
part of a more general topic
of distributed systems.
So it actually forms a
bridge between the stuff
we learned about in
networking, and what
we're going to see from
Wednesday over the next six
or seven lectures of the
class, and of the associated
recitations having
to do with fault
tolerant, reliable computing.
And most of the
interesting aspects
of what we're going to talk
about involve techniques
in fault tolerance,
and more techniques
have to do with redundancy
and replication.
And DNS, the domain
name system, which
is the system
we're going to look
at today in the context
of distributed naming
is a bridge because
on the one hand
it covers some of the
aspects of networking
that we talked about.
On the other hand,
it shows an example
of how you can
achieve replication
to achieve fault tolerance.
And were going to study these
techniques systematically
over the next few lectures.
So getting an example in
mind is usually a good idea.
So you've already seen
the network layer,
and you've seen that.
At the network layer,
attachment points on the network
are identified by IP
addresses in the internet
are more generally identified
by network layer addresses.
So as an example on the
Internet are IP addresses.
And, this is the name that's
used by the network layer
to identify attachment points
anywhere on the network.
And in fact, there's a
name that's used by the end
to end layer to name one
endpoint of connection.
So in fact if you think
about it and go back
to our very early
lecture on naming,
an address is
really just a name,
but a name that's been
overloaded with information
that allows the user of that
name to locate this object.
An address, really, is a name
that has information in it,
overloaded information
in it that actually
allows for it to be located.
And in fact, an IP
address is nothing other
than a name that tells you
where in the Internet topology,
the entity being named by
this IP address is located.
So my computer is
something like 18.31.0.35.
It doesn't mean anything
other than the fact
that somewhere on
this Internet topology
there is this big,
complicated graph.
And that address
allows you to do
routing in the geography
of that topology.
It has nothing to do with
real-world geography.
It just allows you to do
routing in that topology.
Now, in principle, you
could build every Internet
application, and have users
interact with Internet
applications purely with
these network layer addresses.
But that would be
quite inconvenient.
I mean, you would
then have to be
sending e-mail to your friends,
or not, with Joe at MIT.edu.
But, you'd have to do
Joe at some IP address.
And, it's pretty hard and
complicated to remember.
So the first problem with
just using pure network layer
addresses that we
want to solve today,
and we will solve to some
degree, although not completely
is to come up with a
better way of naming things
that are more convenient.
And you already know the answer.
The answer is you send
e-mail to Joe at MIT.edu.
You go to the 6.033 website
at MIT.edu/6.033 or some other
equivalent thing that
leads to the same page.
You don't actually think about
names in terms of IP addresses.
So in fact, to a
large extent, the fact
that these are human
understandable and names
that are mnemonics that
you can easily remember
is a good thing.
And so we do actually
want to come up
with a way of
naming things that's
independent of IP addresses.
The second goal
here is to come up
with a naming scheme with
a solution that allows
some degree of modularity.
As you know, names
provide a level
of indirection between the
thing that you want to get to,
and the handle that you
want to associate with it.
And that level of
indirection, if we come up
with a good way
of doing this, it
will allow us to do a few
things like, for example, I
can tell you that the
website for MIT.edu,
for the institute's
homepage is MIT.edu.
And, behind that, I could change
the actual computers on which
the website is located.
And I could do
that independently
of telling other people
of any change in it,
whereas if I told them that the
website was at a particular IP
address, then every
time I moved a page,
moved the pages from
one computer to another,
I have to tell
everybody in the world
that the website has changed.
And we'd like to minimize
doing that kind of thing.
And so, the domain name
system provides a solution
to this problem.
DNS provides a solution
Most of you have
already heard of this.
It maps between what are
formerly called domain names,
but what we are
going to just call
host names for convenience.
It maps between host
names and records.
And it turns out there are many
different kinds of records.
And we're going to look at a few
of them in this lecture today.
But for your mental
model right now,
just assume that it maps between
host names and IP addresses.
So it turns out
that an IP address
is just one example of a record
called an address record.
But the general goal
of DNS is to map
between host names and records.
And, there is a variety
of them, as I said.
For now, just assume
they are IP addresses.
So for example, MIT.edu
might be 18 dot whatever
it is as an IP address.
So what are the goals
in designing the system?
So, primarily we're
going to be talking
about how the domain name system
is designed, and how it works.
And as we go along,
we'll see some things
that it does that are
different from other systems
or other ways you can
solve this problem.
There are basically two goals
in the design of the system.
And the first goal is
that it should scale.
In fact, the original motivation
for the domain name system when
it came about in
the early 80s was
that it was becoming
extremely inconvenient
to manage the mappings between
names of hosts and their IP
addresses in a way that
as the network grew,
and it was growing
pretty rapidly even then,
as the network
grew it turned out
to be a management nightmare.
And to understand
this, basically there's
three ways in which
you can imagine;
there are more than three ways.
But there are three
more obvious ways
in which you could
imagine mapping
between these names
and these records,
so the names and IP addresses.
And the first one
is, in fact, the way
the Internet names were being
managed until DNS came along.
And that's to use a model
that you might think
of as the telephone book model.
It's actually astonishing
the telephone companies use
the telephone book
model where every six
months at your doorstep
there are these three
thick books that show up.
And you're just looking
at it and going,
what do I do with this?
And you lug it to your
home, and by the time
you might use a couple of times,
and then the next big three
books come along.
You actually wonder
why they don't just
put their phone books on the
Web and make it easy to get at.
But the telephone
book model really
is, there's this central
repository of information.
And everybody gets
this information
from the center repository.
But the repository actually
pushes it to everybody.
So it's not really a
queryable (sic) repository.
It's not something you go in
contact on an as needed basis.
So, in fact, every few
months, or in the old days
of the Internet,
everyday in the morning,
every computer would go and
pull the current mapping
between names and addresses
from a central site.
And this model kind of
works for a little bit,
but stopped working.
It stops scaling
on multiple levels.
First of all, the resources
required for everybody
to have to go and collect
this information every day
turns out to be significant.
But it also turns out to
be a scaling bottleneck
more fundamentally from
the standpoint of any time
you add a machine to
your local organization,
you have to go and
tell the central person
that you've added a machine.
And so, at a human
level it doesn't
scale very well
because you can't
allow for this automatically
happen because then people
would sort of willy-nilly
do all sorts of, you know,
just claim that they own various
machines or various names
at various places.
So the telephone book
model is something
that the Internet used to have.
It used to be a
file card host.txt.
And, every computer had a copy
of this file that usually was
current as of a 24 hour period.
So, the second
approach that you could
adapt knowing this
approach of just
sort of pushing a telephone
book periodically doesn't work.
You might actually adapt a
model, a centralized server
model.
And the central server model
is, the main difference
from the telephone book model is
that nothing is pushed to you.
Instead, imagine a
search engine like, say,
Google or something
like that where
if you want to know the
mapping between a name
and in it the address, you go
and contact this name service,
which turns out to
be a central server.
And it does essentially the
same thing that Google might do.
And this actually isn't
that hard to implement
from a technical
standpoint because Google
does much more than this.
And clearly it works.
But the real problem with
the central server model
is what I alluded
to the last time.
It doesn't handle, when you
assign names to machines,
you want to make sure
that people don't conflict
on these names because these are
well-defined names for machines
on the Internet.
And you need a
model by which you
can decide who is allowed to
name a machine as fool.MIT.edu
and who's allowed to take
X.CNN.com, and so on.
And so, for every
computer in the Internet,
having a central person deal
with deciding whether that's OK
or not isn't a
scalable solution.
And that's why we don't really
adopt that model for DNS.
The model that's
adapted for DNS,
and has a number of other
attractive properties, which
we'll talk about, is the
distributed database model,
or more generally, a
distributed, federated model
where every organization,
and organizations could
be recursively defined to
have sub-organizations.
Every organization
sort of manages
a portion of this
overall global namespace.
And it manages
everything about it.
It manages all of the mappings
between names and records
for that part of the namespace.
And the more names they have,
the more work they have to do.
But nobody else really has
to do that much more work.
And it's a pretty nice
model because everybody
does some amount of work in
terms of technical resources,
and more importantly in terms of
human administrative resources.
And overall, that's
one component
of the scalability
of the system.
And that's one of
the main reasons
why the system turns out to
scale and work very well.
And the second goal
is reliability.
Once you have a
system like this,
and people start
getting used to it,
and applications
start using names,
it had better be the
case that the system
is in fact generally available.
And it better not be the case
that the DNS be the Achilles
heel of the Internet
in terms of, you know,
the network infrastructure
has a very, very
high reliability because
all this running stuff works
out great.
And we find all these
alternate paths.
And things don't work because
I'm not able to get to my DNS.
That had better not be the case.
So we'll see what
techniques DNS uses
to get pretty good reliability.
But the jury is still out as
to exactly reliable it is.
But overall most users will
admit that generally it
seems to work about as well
as the rest of the network.
So, what does DNS do?
Fundamentally, it
provides an abstraction
called a lookup abstraction.
You give it a name.
It returns a record to you.
And you can ask for particular
types of records that you want.
We'll get into that in a second.
So you ask a name, and
you get back a record.
And, there's many ways, and
different operating systems
have different ways in which
this exact function is called.
For example, get
host by name might
be a commonly used way of going
from a name to an IP address.
But, we are going
to just say DNS
resolved just more abstractly.
So an application can invoke
DNS resolve, DNS name,
and get an IP address or
some other record associated
with it.
Now if you think back at the
way we did our idealized naming
model or genetic naming
model, we actually
had a resolve which took a name
and a context as an argument.
And, it returned back the value
that was bound to that name.
So you might ask what the
context is for a DNS resolve.
And it is actually multiple
answers to this question.
The first answer is that
applications specify a context
usually.
So, for example, an
application might specify that.
It wishes to know the
IP address of this name.
For example, if it's
a web browser that
wants to know some
server's IP address,
so it can connect to it
using the TCP connection.
Alternatively, an application
like an e-mail program
might specify that it wants not
the IP address of this machine,
but the name of a machine
that can handle mail
on behalf of this name.
So, for example, if I send
somebody email to ABC.MIT.edu,
my mail program, somewhere
along the way some server would
do a lookup for a
special kind of record
turns out to be called
the MX record, which
is a mail record, which
would then return to caller
not the IP address of MIT.edu,
but the IP address of, in fact,
we learn a name of a machine
that's capable of handling mail
for MIT.edu.
And in general,
that would be very
different from the IP address
associated with MIT.edu.
So that's established
as a context.
And more generally, there
is a DNS configuration file.
There is some DNS
configuration on registry,
or whatever it is depending on
the system that you have that
tells this resolve step
what context in which
the name must be resolved.
So just for example, you
might have a machine,
cricket.MIT.edu, another
machine cricket.berklee.edu.
And DNS resolve might call
DNS resolve of cricket.
And when the
application calls that,
the program doing
the resolution needs
to know what
context to do it in.
And often, that's specified
in the DNS configuration.
So on Windows and UNIX,
there is this thing
called a search path.
And you go through a
set of search paths
that provide this context.
So will see this in
more detail later today.
Now users themselves,
and there's
an important point here about
lookups, and how lookups
are to be distinguished
from something else that
are called search.
Now, these names are generally
very useful for programs
because they allow
modularity to occur,
where it no longer are you
worried about services being
associated with IP addresses.
You can move your website
between IP addresses
of the back without
telling everybody about it.
So from that
standpoint this name
to record mapping a DNS with
lookups is very, very useful.
In terms of convenience, the
DNS is not the whole story
because although you
most often send email
to people with fool@MIT.edu
so you remember
that or you have some other
file in which you find
that information very
easily, more generally
speaking people often don't,
we need something in addition
to just lookups.
Human users need something
in addition to lookups.
And the general term
given to that is search.
So for example Google provides
search on the Internet.
And tomorrow's recitation
talks a little bit
about one aspect of that.
And in fact, it's an
interesting discussion
because you will
find from the reading
tomorrow that users were using a
search engine to essentially do
a lookup task where they would
go to Google and type CNN.com
when in fact if they
already knew to CNN.com
they could just as well have
typed it on their URL window.
And that's sort of the
way real users turned out
to use the Web.
But over peer-to-peer
applications that most of you
might be more familiar with
than I am have a form of search.
And those applications are
interesting because they
do searches on all sorts of
attributes of the content
that you want, and by and
large don't really use
DNS in a particularly,
if they use it
at all it's sort of incidental.
They probably don't
even need to use it.
So it's not like all
Internet applications
require DNS in order to work.
In fact, there are
plenty of applications
that don't need DNS at all.
So, and they benefit
a lot from search.
OK, so let's get back to
DNS and talk a little bit
about a few different topics.
We're going to start
first with the namespace,
and how it works.
And then were going
to talk about how
name resolution works.
And then we're going to talk
about things like performance
and scalability and robustness.
So the DNS namespace has
two properties to it.
The first is, in both
of these are nice ideas,
and hit upon a theme,
or at least one of which
hits upon a theme
we've covered in 6.033.
DNS is a hierarchical system.
And it's a structured namespace.
I'll describe what
structured means in a moment.
So the way our DNS
namespace works
is it's a hierarchical system
which is structured as a tree.
And at the top of the tree
there is a little circle
which really is a dot.
And I'm going to
call that the root.
So, everything
starts at the root.
And the root is the
root of this namespace.
And it's a tree.
The namespace is divided
into A, a bunch of domains.
And domains are divided
into subdomains.
And subdomains are
recursively divided
into sub-subdomains, and so on.
And in fact, the
depth is arbitrary.
It could be arbitrarily long.
In practice, nobody
really has need for depth
more than four or five.
And, in fact, 90% of the names,
or more than 90% of the names
are pretty flat.
You don't go more
than two levels down.
So at the top level, this is
pretty familiar to most of you.
You would have com, and
edu, and net, and org,
and gov, and a few others.
And these things, there
is actually about 13
of them right now.
These things are called generic,
top-level domains, so generic
in the sense that they
are not really associated
with any country, for example.
And then in addition
to this, you
have a whole bunch of
country codes like dot US,
and I don't know how
many countries there are,
but there's a large
number of them.
So those things are country
code top level domains.
And they are not that
interesting in that there's
nothing different about
them from anything else.
So we may as well just look at
the generic top-level domains.
OK, and edu gets divided into
MIT and other places that don't
matter and so on and so forth.
So you might end up down here.
You might have www, or
website, or for whatever
the student's from.
I don't know who
actually owns this.
C sale might be here.
EECS might be here.
And I might have a
machine underneath here,
let's say, X just
around a machine.
And, the thing about
the DNS namespace
is that every label here,
this is a label, right?
So the way you read this is
if you start at any label
here and go upward, you can
read it out from bottom to top.
So you would say com is
an example of a label.
MIT, edu, root is a label.
So that's read as MIT.edu dot.
And usually people
omit the trailing
dot because it's implicit.
Or you X.csale.MIT.edu dot is
another fully formed, what's it
called, fully
qualified domain name.
OK, that's sort
of the correct way
to read it out is
from bottom to top.
Now, every node
here is associated
with some information.
And that's what
this record means.
OK, some nodes might
have nothing in it,
but in general, every
node is associated
with some information.
So, for example, X might
have information here.
I'm just going to
call it INFO for now.
But, X might have
associated with it an
A record, which is
an IP address record.
I'll describe that in a moment.
But it might have other
things associated with it.
In fact, DNS is pretty flexible.
You could define your own record
and put that into the system,
and have applications
that read from it.
It's pretty opaque to it.
It doesn't really require; if
you have something new that
comes up and you want to use
it, you could stick it into DNS
and retrieve it out.
So people put all sorts
of things now into DNS.
For example, there
are weird proposals.
But in GPS
coordinates of a name.
So if you know MIT.edu isn't
going to move very much,
then put in the GPS coordinates.
You might find applications
that find it useful.
For example, if you are some
mobile computing application,
you might find it useful.
So there's all sorts of things
you could stick into the DNS.
And people have come up with
all sorts of very wacky things,
including telephone
numbers in DNS.
It's very flexible.
So not only are the
leaves associated
with things with
information, but you
can have information at any
level, any node in the tree
has information
associated with it.
And the scale of this namespace
today is extremely vague.
I mean, I don't know the exact
number of things there are,
but I've read that
about 500 million,
I don't know if it's 250
million or 500 million,
somewhere in between, there
are that many registered names
in the system in aggregate.
That's a pretty big number.
Now, it's a very big number.
So you need a way in which
you can make the system scale.
And that's done using a really
nice idea called delegation.
And more than any technical
decision that was made in DNS,
I mean, we're going to
talk about some of them
like caching and all
this other stuff.
But more than any
technical decision,
delegation is really
the reason DNS scales.
And, it's ultimately
really the reason
why DNS is pretty successful.
So, what is delegation?
The best way to understand
it is recursively.
So the root at the top
is centrally owned,
and it's owned by
a trusted entity.
So what that means
is that any name that
ends in root, ultimately
the authority for that name
rests with whoever
owns and runs root.
And if you paid attention to
the press, and the newspapers,
or magazines, you'll
see that there's
this fight for the root
that's ongoing right now
over the past few years.
And, the current owner of the
root and things associated with
it, and who essentially
controls the namespace,
is an entity called
ICANN, I-C-A-N-N,
and there's a lot of
politics associated with it.
Now, continuing down
on the delegation idea,
the next layer down from the
root, the technical term for it
is top-level domain because
it's at the top level: TLD, OK?
And, these top-level
domains that
are delegated from the
root, and it's really hard
to come up with a
new top-level domain.
In relation to these,
you have a few more.
But you don't really come
up with them willy-nilly.
You kind of have to go
through a long procedure
before the root decides to
delegate the top-level domain
to somebody else.
And now it's recursive
from here on.
Every label here can be
sub-delegated arbitrarily
by only contacting the
owner of that label.
So once you get to com, you
don't have to go further down.
You just have to go to whoever
happens to own the com label
and tell them that
you want to register
a new portion of the
namespace with that.
So, for example, MIT must
have gone at some point
to the owner of edu
and said, I want MIT.
And, there's some
out-of-band human procedure
that occurs before the
other party is convinced
that this MIT is a
legitimate entity,
and allocates this name
to it, and likewise.
Whoever wanted CSALE went to
the person who runs MIT's name.
This is called a zone,
this DNS namespace
and told it that
it wanted CSALE,
and established by human efforts
rather than anything technical
that it wanted that portion.
Now, the reason it
scales is you can kind of
add machines, you know, names
at the bottom, not machines
but names anywhere
here without really
having to go all the way up.
You just need to go up to
whoever owns your parent label
and convince them
that you want a name.
So if I want to
add a machine, Y, I
don't really have to go and
talk to even anybody at MIT.
I just have to talk
to the person who
runs the CSALE
namespace and tell them
that I want a name, Y.
And I can, then,
sub-delegate that name.
I could, today, connect a
computer X.CSALE.MIT.edu
have in this IP address
with it, and tomorrow
decide I don't really
want X to be a computer.
I want it to be the name of
my research group or whatever,
and then have machines
underneath it which
are Y.X.CSALE.MIT.edu.
What I do with the
label is my business.
And there's no rule that
these are IP addresses.
In fact, these are nothing.
These are just labels.
And I can associate arbitrary
amounts of information
I want with that label.
So, domains can be
formed anywhere in tree.
And that's really
nice because you
don't have to go back
to a central entity
in order to add these names.
And that's the main reason
why the central server
model doesn't really fly.
OK, so examples
of records, we've
already seen a few of these.
So let's look in more detail at
what this info could contain.
Like I said, it's very flexible.
You can have all sorts of
things you add in here.
But there's a few
very common ones.
The first one is called
an A record, which
stands for an address record.
And, it's what you might expect.
It's an IP version four
address for a name.
So, X.CSALE.MIT.edu,
whatever its IP address is.
So, that's stuck
in this database.
It's really maintained
in a file on the name
server that handles that name.
You might have MX, which stands,
the X is for mail exchanger.
So, it's mail exchanger.
So, that's for email.
So, when I send email to
you@MIT.edu, somewhere
along the way
there's a lookup done
for not the IP
address of MIT.edu,
but the MX record for MIT.edu.
And in general, the MX
record could be anywhere.
If MIT decided to outsource
its email functionality
to some other
company, the MX record
would just point to
some name of a mail
server in that other company.
So it doesn't even
have to be local to us.
There's another one that's
interesting in the context
of stuff we've seen before
called a C name, which
stands for a canonical name.
But a C name is
really a synonym.
This is where you can say
there are many names that
really mean the same thing.
So, for example, to take
a very real example,
there used to be AI Lab
and LCS, and now there's
the same lab, CSALE.
Now, there are a lot of
subdomains from LCS.MIT.edu,
and AI.MIT.edu.
And sort of it's a
nightmare to have
to go and change all
of the DNS entries
for all of the machines.
So the standard way in which
you manage this kind of thing
is to set up these C names,
which says [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
NMS.LCS.MIT.edu.
That's what it was.
You just set up a C name
that says NMS.LCS.MIT.edu,
there's a C name for
NMS.CSALE.MIT.edu.
So, you don't have to do
anything more other than set up
these synonyms.
And everything else just sort
of continues to work out.
There are other useful things
you could do with C names.
For example, if you
decide you want,
you're running your Web
server on one machine,
and then you want to change
it over to another machine
but not have to tell the
whole world about it, what you
do is you tell everybody that
your Web server's running,
let's say, MIT.EDU.
And then you set up a
C name for that MIT.edu
to machineone.MIT.edu.
It's another name.
And then someday you decide to
change from machineone.MIT.edu
to machinetwo.MIT.edu.
All you have to do is to
change this one mapping
in the backhand in the DNS
that maps from MIT.edu,
set up a C name mapping
to a different machine,
and that's all you have to do.
You don't have to tell
anybody else about the change
that you've made.
So, it's very useful.
And this is just an example
of a more general concept
that we've seen already
called a synonym.
In the fourth thing,
which is actually
what we're going to
spend most of our time
on today, for the rest
of today, is called
an NS record, which is
a name server record.
And, this is the
thing that's really
going to help us figure
out how to implement
DNS resolve in a scalable way.
I will describe what a name
server record is in a moment.
So if you look at
this tree, associated
with many of the
labels in the tree
are not just A records, which
are generally associated,
but also things
called NS records.
And, what an NS record
says is that, let's say
there's an NS record
associated with MIT.edu.
What it says is
that that NS record
gives the name of the machine
that's responsible for managing
all of the names that
end with MIT.edu.
So, for example, edu
wouldn't know anything
about, in general, edu may
not know anything about how
CSALE.MIT.edu is really mapped.
But all edu needs to know
is what the NS record is
for MIT.edu so that as
you'll see in this procedure,
you'll see that occasionally
things at the top of the tree
will get requests
for a given name,
and they need to know what
to do with the full name.
And, the way they'll
do it is they'll
find out that they don't know
anything about the full name.
But they know about other people
who know more about that name.
And that's going to
be implemented using
this thing called an NS record.
So I'll show this
with an example.
I think it'll
become pretty clear.
So the way in which
applications use DNS is you
have an application
that wants to called
DNS resolve on a DNS name.
And, there's a piece
of software that
usually runs on every computer
called a stub resolver.
OK, and a stub resolver
is just something
that allows
applications to not have
to worry about this whole RPC
mechanism that DNS involves,
that DNS entails.
So, that's just an abstracted
way into the stub resolver.
So the stub resolver really
does all of the work.
So the way the stub
resolver works is,
and the way DNS
resolution works is
that the stub resolver really
can send a DNS request that it
has from the application to any
name server that it wants to.
And later on we'll talk about
how you pick this name server.
And there are lots of
these name servers around.
On the internet, it's a massive
distributed infrastructure.
And, the infrastructure
consists of people,
of nodes that have
responsibility
for different portions
of this namespace.
So, you send a request
to any name server,
and they all participate
in this system together,
these name servers to
help resolve names.
So let's take an example here.
Let's say it's X.CSALE.MIT.edu.
So, at this point in
general the name server
knows nothing about
X.CSALE.MIT.edu.
And it's plan's
going to be that it's
going to send this request out
to the root name server, OK?
And for now, assume that the
root name server is well-known,
that is, the IP
address of the name
server in charge of the root.
So everybody has
a name server that
got associated with themselves.
Assume that the IP address of
the name server of the root
is just well known
to everybody, OK?
So it sends
X.CSALE.MIT.edu all the way
to the root name server.
And the root name
server is actually
going to look at this
thing and say, well, you
want to know the A record.
You might want to know the A
record for X.CSALE.MIT.edu.
It says, but I
don't actually know
what the IP address
associated with this name is.
But I do know somebody
who can tell you
more because I do know who
runs the name service for edu.
So, it comes back with
the response that's
also called a referral saying,
well, I don't know the answer,
but here's where you need to
go in order to find out more.
And that's done by sending back
the name server, or in fact
more generally a
set of name servers,
but sending back the
NS records for nodes
that handle the edu domain.
So that just comes back at you.
And now, you now know
one or more name servers
for the edu domain.
So, let me write that here.
And this name server then
goes back to this edu domain
and says, OK, tell me what the
IP address for X.CSALE.MIT.edu
is.
And, notice that
at all stages, it's
sending the full name
because there's always
some chance that these
nodes have the answer,
and we'll get to why that
might be in a few minutes.
But you always
send the full name.
And the edu name server
record in this case
is, in general,
going to say, well,
I don't know about
X.CSALE.MIT.edu.
But I do know that MIT
came and delegated from me.
So I do know the name server
record associated with MIT
because it delegated from me.
And in general, everybody
has to know the name server
records for the people
one level down from them.
So it sends back this
information saying, well,
I don't know what it is.
But here's a referral to
the name server for MIT.edu.
And this procedure
basically continues.
So this is MIT.
Actually it's just the
MIT.edu name server.
And you just go back and
forth until eventually you
get to the main server
for CSALE.MIT.edu, which
by definition maintains
the mapping for everything
of the form NAME.CSALE.MIT.edu.
And so, you get the answer.
Or you get something that
says X is not actually
registered in which case you get
a no-such-domain error message.
Actually it's a no-such-domain
error code, which you then
interpret as saying, OK,
there is no such name that's
been registered.
Now there's a couple
of things of note here.
The name server records
associated with the domain
really have to have very
little to do with that domain.
In fact, the name
server record for,
forget the root
names for a moment.
The name server records
for the edu domain
don't actually
have to end in edu,
or don't have to end in
anything that relates to edu.
In practice, in
fact, today they're
of the form something.NSTLD.com.
I mean, they have nothing
to do with the edu domain.
And, this is an important point.
You could associate here any
label, any name of a name
server that's willing to
manage the delegation,
manage the entries
in your database.
They don't actually have to
match the same domain name.
And, this is a very
powerful feature
of the namespace of
the way DNS works
because it's not like this
thing has to be something.edu,
and here the name
servers for MIT.edu
have to be actually
something.MIT.edu.
In practice, edu is not
managed by anything.edu.
It's something, NSTLD.com.
In practice, it so happens
that MIT.edu happens
to run its own name
servers; that's
something like bitsy.MIT.edu.
But that's by no
means a requirement.
So there's a couple
of problems that we
need to solve about this basic
mechanism it does what we saw
was that once you know the
root name server record,
then you could go back and forth
because everybody knows how
the names one level down
from them have been delegated
and knows the name server
entries for those delegates.
And then you get
the final answer.
So there's a few things
we need to solve.
The first one is bootstrap.
There's actually a couple of
aspects of this bootstrap.
The first one is, how does
this any name server here know
the name servers of the root?
And, the answer here is
that there's no magic.
I mean, you just have to know.
And, in some sense,
in all naming systems,
ultimately there is, at some
level of this name discovery
procedure, at some level there's
out of band machinery that
has to get in and be involved.
And the way this works out is
that people publish the name
server records for the root.
They post it on websites.
They publish it
on mailing lists.
And you can figure DNS
software is configured
to manage those entries.
And there are proposals and
protocols for automatically
updating it and so on.
But you've got to
be very careful
with technical
solutions like that
because you want to make sure
that malicious bodies don't
pretend that they're telling you
the correct name server entry
because once they
usurp DNS functioning,
they could do a lot of damage.
In practice, in fact, DNS
is not particularly secure.
It's a different discussion
as to whether that's
important or not.
But the way this root
name server mapping works
is that everybody just knows.
It's widely published.
You go to Google and you'll
just find the answer.
It's also on all sorts
of mailing lists.
So the first one
is root identity.
The second issue is,
how does the stub
connect to any name server?
Would it just pick at random?
How does it find the name
server that it can connect to?
And the answer to this
is that this is actually
running on your computer.
The stub result was
running on your machine.
It's a library in your machine.
So, one approach, and
the most common approach
today is that you
might obtain it
when you obtain an IP address
using a protocol like DCP where
you turn on your computer and
you get an IP address using
some protocol.
That protocol, some
gateway upstream
might tell you which
name server to use.
So if you have a
computer at home,
your Internet service provider
would have something set up.
So they would tell you
what name server to use.
So this can be done using
a mechanism like DCP.
Or like in the old
days, and these days
if you want to do this kind
of work, it's done manually.
For example, you could
go into some registry
somewhere or file
like Kazaa.com.
Then you just start stuff in.
The second issue that we need
to spend some time about, which
we are going to spend the
next five or so minutes on
is performance.
And the main point
about performance
is that if you look at that
picture for how names are being
resolved, if
somebody at Berkeley
wants to resolve
X.CSALE.MIT.edu,
there's a huge
number of roundtrips
that they have to do to
all sorts of name servers
all over the world, or at
least all over the country
before they can
figure out what the IP
address is from a machine.
And this is a little bit
silly because often, they
might want to connect
to your webpage
and get a 4 kB thing, which
takes a couple of roundtrips
to get.
And, in order to
do that, they're
spending a huge number
of roundtrips latency,
use latency in getting
this right answer.
So the approach that we're
going to take to solve
the too-much-too-many roundtrips
problem is an approach
you've already seen.
We're going to use caching.
And, in order for
this caching to work,
there is actually
something in this picture
that you have to understand
in a little bit more detail
about two different
kinds of name resolutions
that are really going on.
The first kind of
name resolution
that's going on in DNS
is the kind of resolution
that the edu name server
or the MIT.edu name server
is doing in this
picture, and that's
called iterative resolution.
Iterative resolution
says the following.
If I ask you to do some work
for me to resolve a name,
if you don't know the
answer you just tell me,
I don't know the answer,
but you go here and find out
the answer.
So you're getting these
pointers referring you
to the right place.
The second kind of
resolution that's going on
is the kind of resolution
that this box is doing,
this any name silver box.
And it's doing something
called recursive resolution
because what's going on here is
the stub resolver's telling it,
here's a name;
resolve it for me.
And what he's doing
is basically saying,
OK, I'll resolve it for you
and get you the final answer.
I'm not going to give
you a referral back
to other places,
which means eventually
once it figures out the
answer, if there is one,
it's going to know the
answer even though it did not
originate the query.
And the moment you have
recursive resolution,
it means that you
can cache the answer
because if somebody else comes
and asks you the same query,
you already have
the answer cached.
And notice that
this benefit doesn't
accrue if you're doing
purely iterative resolution.
If everybody was just
sending referrals back
to the stub resolver,
the only caching
you'd really
primarily be gaining
is for all of the requests that
are common to this computer
because nobody is actually
cashing in getting
any answers along the way.
Nobody's even getting any
referrals along the way.
Only the node that's
starting the name resolution
is going to be getting any
answers or any referrals
at all.
So the secret to getting good
DNS performance is for certain
nodes, for certain name servers,
to agree to do recursive
resolution --
And an example of that is any
name server in this picture.
So now if you have, a
lot of the computers here
with a lot of applications
running on it, all of which
use the same name server,
and that name server
is configured to recursively
resolve names, then
that name server
benefits from being
able to cache the answers
to previous DNS lookups.
But notice that they can
cache two kinds of answers,
and one of which is much more
important than the other.
The first kind of
answer they can cache
is the final answer
that you get back
that says X.CSALE.MIT.edu is
at a particular IP address.
So the next time somebody
goes to X.CSALE.MIT.edu,
they have the
answer right there.
But if you look at the
statistics of DNS requests,
there is some commonality
in that everybody
wants to go to www.CNN.com
or Google.com or Yahoo.com,
and so on.
But, there's a huge
number of requests
going to machines
like yours and mine
which aren't running
anything interesting.
And you are really
the only people
interested in those machines.
So really what's
going on, and why
caching helps is that not only
are the final answers being
cached, these referrals
are being cached.
So for example, [any name?]
already knows the root,
but now after the first
request it knows the mapping
for edu's name service.
And after the first
one to MIT.edu,
it can cache the mapping for
MIT.edu's name server as well.
So, the next time somebody
asks for anything.MIT.edu,
this name server doesn't
have to go all the way back
to the root.
In fact, it doesn't even have
to go all the way back to edu.
It just has to
start with MIT.edu
whose name service entry it
already has in its cache.
And, that really
is the reason why
the DNS scales very, very well.
It's because it does caching.
But the real key is that
it's caching referrals.
It's caching these
name server entries
associated with these labels.
It's getting some benefit from
caching the final answers,
but it's really getting a lot of
benefit from caching referrals.
Now, of course, when
you catch things,
you have to worry about being
stale because you certainly
don't want to cache it forever.
If you cached it forever, then
nobody could change anything.
So let's say you
decide to change
the mapping of www.MIT.edu's
A record from one IP address
to another.
How do you tell the whole
world that you've changed it?
Well, there's two high-level
strategies for this.
One is to somehow keep
track of all the people
who have cached it and
invalidate entries.
And a few lectures
from now, we'll
look at ways in which
that kind of approach
might be made to work
for different systems.
DNS deals with it in
sort of a different way.
It doesn't worry
about invalidation.
Instead, it sets
expiration time on entries
also called TTL
is a time to live.
That's an abused and
overloaded term in networks.
But it's really an
expiration time.
It says that here's the answer
to any of these questions,
to a referral or to
the final answer.
Here's the mapping.
And, it's valid for
such and such a time,
OK, like it could be anywhere
from 15 seconds or 30 seconds
to three hours or a day.
Usually it's a day or two.
It's usually never more
than a couple of days
because you reach the point
of diminishing returns.
One request every two
days is not a big deal.
So usually it's on the
order of several seconds
if you want the mapping
to be fine-grained,
or an hour, or a day.
And, after that, any access made
after that to the same entry,
whether it be a referral or
whether it be a final answer,
has to go back to the server
that's authoritative that's
responsible for that entry.
So, for example, you went
for the first time doing
the lookup of this
name, and you got back
that MIT.edu's name
service was some name,
and that it was
valid for an hour.
Then the first
request that happens
for anything.MIT.edu from here
after an hour has to go here.
I mean, assuming
that edu is still
a valid, hasn't yet expired.
This entry has to go here.
So, if you look at a time
sequence of when you go,
when you actually go back to the
server responsible for a name,
you can kind of divide up
time into these chunks which
are the expiration
time intervals assuming
they don't change.
They are set by the server.
And then, you might have
accesses in between like this.
And the only accesses
that go to the server
responsible for the
name are the first ones
after every expiration.
So, this is the
basic story for how
you get reasonably
good performance,
and save a lot of
roundtrips in DNS.
And the real reason for the
scalability of the domain name
system is a combination of
administrative delegation.
So you don't have
some human being
involved in every name that's
being added to the network.
It's distributed across
different organizations.
And the fact that
you have caching,
in particular your
caching these name
server records, which means
that you can save a lot of load
on the root and on the
edu or com name servers.
Originally, the
designers of DNS, one
thought that they
had was that DNS
would scale very well because
the name space is extremely
divided and hierarchical, which
means that you were gaining
a lot from the hierarchy.
And that's why it would scale.
But that's actually not
true because more than 90%
of the domain namespace is not
hierarchical in any deep sense.
Everybody is something.com.
Everybody of importance
is something.com,
or wants to be something.com.
And so, most of
the load gets here.
So, there's no
real deep hierarchy
that you're
benefiting from here.
That's usually
some flatname.com.
But it's divided.
And it's delegated.
And that's the really
nice thing about it.
So you are gaining
much more from the fact
that it's delegated.
You'd probably gain the same
scalability is everything
were just something.root, OK?
We didn't really
need too much of this
in terms of scalability,
although it's very convenient
to be able to do delegation.
But primarily it seems
to be universities
that take advantage of
this kind of depth here.
Most companies tend not to
pay much attention to depth.
But yet, the system scales
because it is, in fact,
administratively delegated.
So one word on replication.
The DNS name servers responsible
for these names are replicated.
You can't set up a DNS name and
have a name service associated
with it.
A DNS name server record has
to have at least two entries,
and you have to be on
two different networks.
And that's one way so that
if one of them is down
you can get to the other.
And unfortunately it turns out
that that simple rule is often
violated.
Probably the most
celebrated incident here
was Microsoft's update
site, or one of the sites
was down for more than 24 hours.
And in the end it turned
out in all these cases
to be a complicated set of
reasons for why it failed.
Nothing fails for
a simple reason.
But one of the root
causes was that they
had DNS name servers
that were replicated
but that happened to be behind
the same Ethernet switch
on the same subnet,
which is not recommended.
But that's what they had.
So it's the kind
of thing that you
need to be careful about doing.
So I'm going to stop here.
And from Wednesday, we will
talk about fault tolerance.
The recitation for tomorrow
is a very short paper
called Google and 9/11.
But tomorrow you'll see a little
bit about how Google works.